usually I have to take something to see
shit like this what the hell are you
guys doing preparing for the new law
they're about to pass what law the one
bill abolish crying what law yeah we'll
spread chaos in its wake it'll ethically
destroy humanity stands for whoa a lot
of split up Pinky and the brain that's
not a law it could be no again it makes
so much sense it clearly does it just
seems like the road America's going down
it's amazing how much it's not and how
would you know mr. expert cuz it has
nothing to do a crime crime is about
breaking the law for your own personal
gain and this amazingly has nothing to
do with it it doesn't matter we set up
security perimeters all around studio
just in case it causes worldwide panic a
suspect it would cause worldwide
indifference but haven't you seen the
purge bird fuck don't max movie
everybody fell for hey if that could
happen shoka's splitting up pinky in the
brain it's not fair just as they're
legalizing gay marriage the urge
wouldn't happen it never could happen
and that's why it's so baffling you with
such a success
with its equal having come out and
having it be number one again at the box
office
well almost number one damn dirty eight
the purge is one of those surprise hits
that literally nobody can identify with
the idea is the not-too-distant future
has basically abolished crime because
one night a year they may crime legal an
interesting idea for a dark satire or
maybe a clever comedy but no the film
plays it up like this could really
happen and that we shouldn't let it
happen because apparently we're too
stupid to realize it's a bad idea just
look at how ridiculously serious it
takes its advertising
Oh
yes nothing like a version of Oh
beautiful being sung to blood gushing
innocent killing homicidal psychotics
slaughter and Families now the gay or
ethnic person saying it that be call for
how big help maybe America is more
fucked up than we realized if we're dumb
enough not only to take this shit
seriously but also give it a sequel
let's see how this movie shows what the
flying hell is wrong with us even if it
doesn't in a way that wasn't intent so
let's not waste a time will you guys
knock it off this is the purge we see
the film opens in the year 2022 yep we
only have eight years until this plan is
put into place we're so close to America
it could happen any day I think it's
more likely we'll be dressing like this
in a few months than having the purge in
a few years I guess and just to give you
a taste of how subtle and non
pretentious this films gonna be here's a
bunch of intense violence set to calming
music
because it's irony if they don't fit
together will the future know that and
just when you're wondering how an intro
could be any less subtle one hell of a
puzzle piece falls into your lap now it
makes sense
suddenly so many elements come together
I can just see good old BAE getting high
off his ass one night saying I want to
feel deep but I don't want to have to
use my brain for it where's that purge
script the film opens with a home
security salesman named James played by
Ethan Hawke driving home on the day of
the purge noticing quite an unrealistic
amount of people still in their
neighborhoods get one last walk in
before lockdown huh yeah should do the
system checker recommended of course the
problem sir uh if I knew crime was gonna
be legal in 24 hours I'd probably tell
my family
hey gang how about that vacation to
Kanna it's one of those friendly weekend
visits to the Ned Flanders of North
America then the more I think about they
may not be the safest either it's a rape
whistle
what the fuck people put out flowers to
show they support the purge others talk
on the radio about what kind of crimes
they're gonna do beep from Northern
Virginia what's your purge plan I'm
gonna hunt down my boss a son of a bitch
has it coming
well hopefully P for Northern Virginia's
paws doesn't listen to the radio fucking
idiot
and even guys in lab coats explained the
totally believable way the purge works
we are inherently a violent species Wars
genocide murder the denial of our true
selves is the problem the purge not only
contains societal violence to a single
evening but the countrywide catharsis
creates psychological stability by
letting us release the aggression we all
have inside of us oh of course
terrorists drug dealers and bezel errs
people with aggressive mental disorders
all they needed to do was just let out a
little aggression it was so simple the
whole time good lord do you know how
many crime shows who have ended
differently if we knew about that from
the beginning all right Gus if I'm going
to cook for you I need to know that
you're going to kill everybody who will
get in the way of distribution
especially your cell
before turning to such a violent route
have you ever considered hitting a
pillow a pillow yes you'll find it
strangely relaxing my god
you're right my mental stability is
subtly leveling out why do we wanna make
meth anymore maybe I'll open that puppy
farm I'm glad to hear it
now for God's sake please put on a pair
of pants
not until you promised me a cameo it'd
better call Saul so James has a wife
named Mary played by lena headey who
spends most of her time fighting off
jealous neighbors you know not everyone
had the year you did Mary you know some
people are actually saying this
neighborhood paid for that new addition
on your home for people really saying
that relax it's just good old
neighborhood gossip nothing to worry
about
I might be passive-aggressive but
tonight I'll be aggressive aggressive
tight ooh cookies
I hope you're hungry those cookies are
crazy good they're lovely have a safe
night lady yeah well we established
ourselves can't wait to show up
obviously just for the climax woven like
a quilt
even before the purge a little bit of
creeping seems to be going around
Christ you scared me to death
yeah you really got me there movie for a
second I swore a tiny neat I need I need
I need person was going to kill her
good fake out this device was made by
their son sharp who seems to enjoy
monitoring his heartrate sorry I forgot
to take my vitals early by the way
there's a slight deviation in my heart
rate but other than that nothing to
worry about it's never explained why and
never comes back into the movie later
it's just something he kinda likes to do
quirks replacing character identity
since the beginning of this movie they
also have a daughter named Zoe who's
moody because her dad does not approve
of her eighteen year old boyfriend in
English I wrote a story about a man
whose love is so powerful cuts out his
own heart you know you should have cut
off his own penis Zoe Zoe
eating dinner yeah so it's just me and
Charlie don't don't encourage kids do I
have to savagely mutilated ur in the
purge
I'm guessing this world just thinks
we're all good parents for some reason
but I can totally do that
guys look what time it is
well it's later than I thought all right
it's time for lockdown Wow I can't
believe we almost missed that little
detail Oh what the purge is starting
whatevs it's not like we're missing an
episode of chasing live help the movie
starts by saying it's an hour until the
purge begins that means they have to
drive home talk to neighbors start
dinner set the table eat dinner and
prepare the security system during
arguably the fastest sunset the town's
ever known call me crazy but I would
leave so little time in between mental
stability and when death becomes the
news selfie I mean I know the rest of
the world relies on the honor system by
not committing crimes the rest of the
year but somebody would start early
catching you off your guard and then
leave the country while the cops are
shut down or do they respect the purge
too much to break the law this
is not a test weapons of class four and
lower have been authorized for use
during the purge police fire and
emergency medical services will be
unavailable until tomorrow morning at
7:00 a.m. blessed be our new founding
fathers and America a nation reborn took
the new founding fathers
I'm sure the speeches these new founding
fathers gave it in just as well as the
other great leaders of the past the only
thing we have to say is fear so ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
just kill some people right right and
just like before the film praises the
effectiveness of the purge but never
addresses mental illness territory
disputes drug possession or anything
that doesn't fall under mere pent-up
rage they just say it works eradication
of the so-called non-contributing
members of society
this night saved our country crime is
down the economy is flourishing because
it works on deny the fact is is working
that's right the purge works just like
how somebody can take 65 million dollars
and apparently make a film like food
fight don't question how illogical it is
that it just works one of the other
phrases they seem to repeat a lot in
this movie is release the Beast release
the Beast release the Beast release the
Beast boys let the killing commence
quite a terrifying combination of words
right whoo I think I saw that at a
Jagermeister at one
we see a homeless guy trying to hide
from some violent kids by screaming at
the top of his lungs that'll work as the
Sun decides to let him in yep
the little kid opens the door it's not
like the top seller of the security
system would actually be around his
security system buddy all that high-tech
gadgetry doesn't do much if you give in
to it's one simple design flaw the door
must be closed to make things worse
Zoe's boyfriend snuck in before the
lockdown and tells her that he wants to
just talk to her dad about allowing him
to date her mr. Sandin James he hasn't
got a gun I still believe the bird works
on me talk went well hit a few bumps but
I think we can get past that the
boyfriend gets killed the low and behold
a group of young people approach the
door who are chasing the homeless man
down deck our trade now to this movies
credit just when you think it's taking
itself too seriously a saving grace
simply known as Henry enters the film
and by God he either takes absolutely
none of this seriously or every single
molecule of breath he takes on the set
seriously either way he's by far the
most entertaining part of the film just
watch this goof we are some fine young
very educated guys and gals ready to
violate annihilate and cleanse our souls
he's got more ham but a dr. Seuss bark
mister misses the man you're sheltering
is nothing but a dirty homeless Pig a
grotesque menace to our just society who
had the audacity to fight back
please just let his perch he's not gonna
release the Beast he's gonna release the
squeeze if you don't live in by the
aforementioned time we'll release the
Beast on him and on you I just farted
and it's gonna smoke really bad we can
enter any home we want and we will want
as morning is our will on this fine
night what the hell does that mean you
have until our provision to ride
provisions which will help us break into
your elegant home
toodaloo sanded well now we know what
Macaulay Culkin does to every family who
watches Richie Rich so the kids give
them an hour before they try breaking in
to have them hand the man over this
results in the suspenseful part of the
movie where they go through the house
with the power cut by the masked kids
which would make it hard to find the guy
when it they're obviously not going to
call the cops and I'm not kidding the
search goes on for 15 minutes 15 minutes
of them just searching through the dark
and us practically looking at nothing I
don't even know who I'm supposed to be
scared for it the family of course are
the main characters and they're chasing
an injured man crying for help
where the hell am I supposed to be
afraid all the while but children of a
corny are taunting them I guess by doing
non scary things they're supposed to be
scary because they have masks on
well we've tried skipping and we've
tried prancing bets continue to do a
full-on dosey doe do you by your front
door I've seen a moment good son but
thankfully in the middle of their
searching we get yet another scene from
dear young Andrey tell me why haven't
you delivered the filthy swine to me yet
are you protecting him I surely hope no
I'm mr. Sinan no of course not
I'm sorry I'm really trying I'm trying
so hard to be scared by this kid but
he's just so fucking hilarious
he's just projecting so much that he
wants to be scary that it's actually
kind of adorable
I just want to pinch his little supposed
to be frightening cheeks that kind of
behavior sound out he or that Romy they
yeah
come on you can trust a face like that
and a night where all crime is supposed
to be legal how can this go awry I'll go
get you should do that why are they even
blowing all their time on this one damn
house they have 100 years to do whatever
the hell they want and yet they spend it
like 5th graders who just found out they
have cameras on their phones what person
was been so much time to get into a
person's house for such a weak reason a
critic you might want to take a look at
this
film brain hello
mr. critic I heard you're reviewing the
purge yeah what about it you are aware
that I reviewed the film of mine
projector series and I was rather
surprised that you didn't ask me to do a
crossover with you I just did a
crossover film brain if I did another
one to be too repetitive
mr. Craig the film you are watching is a
dirty brainless pile a film that has the
audacity to exist in our cultured
filmgoing society and it deserves to be
eradicated brutally painfully my she
she's really wanted to review this with
me is this what happens when you try to
split up Pinky and the brain will you
shut up
mr. tikrit think I just want to splurge
as I am so entitled
please let me spurge don't brainer I'm
sorry I can't do two in a row maybe
another review in the future
oh I understand of course but the 10
tons of dynamite saline around your
office does not I thought this place
smelled dynamite ehome rain what the
hell that's right I'm bonkers now and if
you don't do a crossover with me I'm
gonna detonate your asses sky-high with
my robot phone your cell phones the dead
near oh yeah that's not that now and I
must be allowed to comment on this
film's cheesiness just allow me to
unleash the cheese all right all right
don't breathe it just give me time to
write something up Oh mr. critic
commercial break maybe very well but do
not disappoint me
anything else oh I'm just a lying my
scary performance to sinky fine you do
you have to do a crossover I can't to be
too redundant you'd risk your own life
for that trust me I have an issue about
being redundant rhyming what are we
gonna do then
you
is he doing anything not really he's
kind of skipping and prancing about I
think he's too distracted about how evil
he's trying to be good I'm gonna keep
reviewing while you guys think I'm a
plan right first we don't tell them
about the splitting up of Pinky and the
brain they're not splitting up
they can eventually catch the guy but
something convinces them not to hand him
over and I use the word something
because I literally have no idea what it
is that convinces them not to do it the
daughter says nothing will be the same
hell even the guy offers to hand himself
over to end all the trouble see your
children take me outside and yet for
some reason they decide to renege I'm
not saying that what they're doing isn't
the right thing I'm just saying their
explanation of how they came to that
conclusion is about as solid as because
it works logic that it just works the
teens are done waiting and decide it's
time to start breaking it you failed to
deliver the homeless swine that piece of
felt that you are protecting exists only
to serve our needs apart
so I bid thee farewell sweet sandins can
we just give this guy's a reality show
like survive a conversation without
squirting milk through your nose or dopa
a Saturday morning show a Saturday
morning show where Henry reads to
children please got somebody make that
happen coming to ABC Family reading with
Henry hello children let's look at
babies first mythos c is for Cthulhu who
sits in his palace and rila one sight of
home would leave most of us
cheering droid and screaming disgust
purge coming this fall to ABC Family so
they break down the high-tech security
system which was amazingly easy to do oh
fuck - these guys stay in business and
the teens come in for the search it's
scary because they're taking something
dark and evil and making it innocent and
fun we have to run that in slo-mo just
to make sure it wasn't too subtle but
just to make sure it isn't let's play
this over it too
Coover look a little Asian Cooper did
you check under the bed
that would be the most obvious hiding
spot I got to find more security cameras
to skip in front of ya
even though the purge has been going on
for several years apparently nobody ever
thought to maybe put on body armor
during it but hey what's the point the
purge just works
yeah I saw that so they don't come back
as zombies but just when he thinks he's
gotten out okay Oh
okay this character hasn't let me down
yet let's see how many traditional movie
psychopath cliches we can fit into 30
seconds can we have the comfort and
killer the whimpering lip over the
beauty of his actions how about the
thankful gratitude for giving him such
an experience thank you for this
unforgettable purge mr. Sandin
there better be a loving kissing there
as Tom it all off with this training of
his suit and hair proving his look is
far more important than the life of
another that's five five psychotic movie
cliches in under 30 seconds oh my god
Henry could never ever die
oh he killed the only enjoyable
character in the film he was filled with
more ham than pony oh right now who's
gonna drill our incredibly for cyou
message into the ground oh great the
characters will only exist in so you
would know who they are in the climax
again like a quilt the truth is you're
ours not theirs James is dead Mary and
the kids walk to do let's tie them up
walk over my hair and your barricades
came down we saw an opportunity to
cleanse ourselves of her hatred yep
because that's how killers talk
everybody I'm sorry I gotta kill you but
the cleansing of my mortal coil has to
be addressed if I'm to be ethically
absolved blood you need so much money
off of us and then you just stuck it in
our faces you all think you're so damn
perfect fat and your cookies are awful
now we're going to kill you and both of
your daughters
so this world is like BioShock Infinite
except with none of the cool stuff and
double the hypocrisy but the homeless
man comes in to save the day your call
just get it over with
tell us quickly oh for God's sake just
do it come on the movies almost over and
Henry was the only entertaining thing
anyway we were gonna play the rest of
this night on motherfucking case so as
you heard she forces everybody to sit
politely until the purge is over bitch a
Lannister always pays her to get out of
my house
cm the neighborhood barbecue thus they
all go home and life goes on as normal
just after 7:00 a.m.
has just concluded the new founding
fathers have released an early statement
saying this was the most successful
purge but wait a minute
it wasn't successful was it haha fucked
up this is one of the most pretentious
ideas that I've ever seen in my entire
life
I mean who would actually be inspired by
such a ludicrous idea ah critic film
brain says he's done scarily frolicking
times up mr. critic where's my review
well I kind of just finished it up film
brain what you file no no no I just want
you to uh finish it off with the closing
thoughts really what would you have me
say well the play this movie is to prove
one thing that the purge is bad well
since we already know that and not a
million years will we ever let something
like this happen it's a pretty fucking
pointless message maybe fills a dark
comedy and exploitation film or
balls-to-the-wall satire but it explains
nothing about how this idea could work
except that it works most of it is just
showing people sneaking around the house
like it's trying to be a gritty
real-life situation but since we know
the logic is bullshit there's no way to
identify with it the only bit of fun is
that Henry character he at least does
something to only batshit crazy and
memorable but for everything else it's
just a pretentious wannabe protest film
that has nothing to protest it's like
that kid who wants attention in your
writing class so he writes what he
thinks his groundbreaking commentary
when really it's just someone
complaining about how there's nothing to
complain about
it's a stupid ridiculous mess well yeah
I can say that and wait a minute already
said that oh yeah oops so I bid thee
farewell critic unleash the chase
oh bloody hell come on yes I am your
father complain lace up alright fine
okay okay let's do this hmm I'm starting
to wonder well I'm River afraid of this
guy look film brain this is already in
my top ten mohs awkward life moments
what do you say we just call it quits
for the night huh
oh hey look the safety was on ah from
how hard I push a button and I blow the
up you
at least speaking the brain are still
together being in the brain or not
sweating up pinky in the brain uh yeah
yeah pretty devastating news huh my god
I love pinky in the brain yes yes well
traumatized by it so much so that I bet
you just want to go home lie in bed and
gorge on Turkish Delight don't you yeah
uh I think I'll do that
why is it celebrity couples not the
steaks yeah we have got to stop that
crazy crumpet from ever coming back here
but how once he figures out the truth
he'll just come back to finish what he
started Tamron are you familiar with the
phrase self-fulfilling prophecy
pinky are you pondering what I'm
pondering
I think shell brain but how can you have
a duck dynasty if none of the people are
ducks damn it pinky can't you get at
least one fucking thing right what no no
captain Yoos not the music but I have
put up with this bullshit for too long
oshi you are the syphilis to everything
I've worked so hard for
you miserable poisonous sack of disease
got it bitch yeah I could have had the
world years ago if you didn't keep
fucking it up oh dear I'll do me a favor
and just just die just die for the sake
of all humanity oh yes that's all you're
good for is what are you sure this is
for a kid show it just say if people
want to hear this for years
oh really all right yeah okay all right
you are pestilence right you're the
pestilence of life we believe in
homicide if I could go back in time to
the moment of your conception
you
who knew because it works